and there was a clip of me where I said
no one looks good at 300 pounds 300
pounds is a lot that's a lot of weight
and some whales started yeah
that was a big guy
yeah well I said no one looks good at
300 pounds so I'm sure you can find an
exception of some jack dude but in
general so on that note I've got a few
facts hilarious to run by okay uh I've
you might have probably seen you know
he's a 10 but she's a 10 but okay so
I'll put some pizza
okay I want to eat you know but um he's
a 10 bot he makes less money than you
he's like well how how much does he make
how much less
I don't get particular
I wasn't ready for the remote oh then
he's still here tan he should be a tin
oh yeah yeah that's it all right cool
she's making peace
he can't drive
um what do you mean he can't try it I
can't drive does he have his license no
he can't drive look like he has no legs
can you drive
um in the US not here I don't have a car
here yeah so wait I I just wanted to why
can't I use it yeah
but he could learn right yeah
it's still in time
I wasn't for Jess all right in the
states it's a little different because
here you have access to public
transportation it's like you don't drive
okay
[Music]
have you seen the size of Dallas bro
the states yeah yeah it's huge I mean
you have to pick him up for date night
basically
um I mean if he's giving me gas money
now somehow I I have driven I gotta I
don't think that's that big of a deal I
think if he could learn I just
surrounded
both of you uh just you were first
is a 10 but he has three baby llamas
three
[Music]
excessive he's productive different
nationalities as well it's a straight
shooter
different nationalities as well
I'm done I say four four five four five
three three okay I don't do kids
he's a 10 but he wants you to stop doing
YouTube because you get abuse online
enhancing to stop doing is he is he
paying for sure
no he's just like you started you
um
six
yeah I would probably say six if he's
not paying anything he's a zero if he's
not if he's telling me to quit my job
and expecting me and we don't have any
kids affecting me just to do nothing
then it's like okay how how are we gonna
get things done
[Music]
you go back to watching the kids on the
playground
after what I've seen on the kids in the
playground oh you're a teacher I taught
PE back in the States and then here I
did like after school program here y'all
scarred me
I call our British kids or act like we
are pieces of [ __ ] yeah yeah right yeah
especially guys boys
American Bullies Are they don't seem
real to me
it doesn't seem real to me like this is
such a jerk Derek
you know here my old school was like
everyone all these kids could do
whatever because they could get away
with everything because they know
our school we're not about to bring a
knife in you know we're not about to
actually get into a proper place yeah
but we were having this conversation the
other day our school our school in
particular was different
this thing I said to you he was like bro
check right now I said shut up
thank you right now I said do it then he
brought the shank out in front of me
[Applause]
let's talk about it we're gonna do it
like that that [ __ ] was gonna give me
crazy work bro hey
please
I was like I was like slightly I sweated
a little bit I was like
Bugatti
come on now man okay I'm still waiting
all right fair enough I've got the
customers
to drive the Honda Civic why am I gonna
act like I'm better than anyone I still
would that's like fuel efficiency
because uh you probably everyone's
always everyone's really seen them viral
clip you don't own a Bugatti from Andrew
Tate oh yeah yeah yeah so Andrew Tate
has been banned from
like or social media now
um apart from Rumble was Rumble
um another social media thing that no
one cares about I mean the bird the
stock prices flew up since he jumped on
it and like they've been getting a lot
of like new people on it yeah basically
it's grown it's got a lot can I twitch
another streaming plan yeah yeah oh is
it like twitch yeah okay okay okay okay
okay okay yeah so um yeah do you agree
with that like
if someone is oh do you agree that he
was bad for young men
no
okay I'm just asking
no what that he was bad for you on for
young men yeah I mean I think there's
worse things on the yeah yeah have you
been on Twitter
that place is
Pornhub now apparently
um
when it started like was it pandemic I
mean it was in the pandemic because it
was a little bit before yeah it was
about despite her independence all these
people would like uh put Clips on their
Twitter first and then be like where's
your only fans I would be thinking these
clips must just be her and laundry no
bro no stuff stuff's happening stuff is
going on Madness
it does send me a tweet right now
I'll say do you have Twitter no you can
change
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible